[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique très
heureux de vous retrouver en direct sur
france 3 bourgogne
plus d'un million de jeunes du monde
entier en grève le 15 mars dernier
ils ont appelé les différents
gouvernements à agir pour le climat
événement à l'appel de la jeune
écologiste suédoise greta tanberg le
lendemain d'autres marches avec des
manifestants de tous âges étaient
organisées quelles sont les motivations
de ces jeunes qui se mobilisent pour le
climat comment peuvent-ils transformer
l'essai de ces dernières semaines les
jeunes sont-ils vraiment prêts à
s'engager durablement et quel message
adressez t-il aux politiques mais aussi
au mouvement écologiste plus largement
on en débat ce matin avec nos invités
béryl rongeait bonjour quand je vous
êtes lycéenne à dijon vous avez
participé à cette marche du 15 mars dans
les rues de dijon tout comme vous alexis
fria bonjour bonjour vous êtes lycéen
chevigny saint sauveur près de dijon et
pour échanger avec vous j'ai demandé un
élu écologiste de nous rejoindre patrice
château bonjour bonjour adjoint au maire
de dijon délégué à l'environnement et
membre d'europe écologie les verts j'ai
également sollicité un militant
associatif pascal blain bonjour bon je
vous êtes porte parole régional de
france nature environnement merci à tous
d'avoir accepté cette invitation vous
qui nous regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission en direct sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag dean
paul bourgogne alors quand on a regardé
ces images partout dans le monde entier
y compris dans notre région on enverra
quelques-unes dans un instant on s'est
posé tous une question pourquoi pourquoi
cet engagement soudain pourquoi cette
urgence pour cette question climatique
béryl ronger qu'est ce que vous nous
répondez
comment vous expliquez ce sursaut de la
jeunesse c'est à la lecture notamment
des rapports du giec
on voit qu'il ya une crise on est dans
une urgence et c'est surtout une
question de pragmatisme maintenant est
ce si l'on met en jeu notre avenir
invite à la lecture des experts du giec
et qui sont donc chargés de nous tenir
informés de la situation
à 16 ans on lit pas les rapports du giec
assuré mois ci ne pas
quand le travail scolaire nous emmène
sur nous défendre a besoin justement de
lire des rapports du giec pour compléter
nos travaux scolaires de recherche oui
oui donc c'est cette urgence la
l'interpellation des experts du giec
vous elle vous parle alexis fria oui
aussi c'est on a parlé dans les médias
très longuement oui il n'ya pas que
leurs rapports du giec
il ya aussi le départ de nicolas hulot
qui a provoqué un sursaut écologique
dans toute la france et même dans les
autres pays et donc il y a urgence et
donc il faut vous avez choisi de vous
mobiliser sur cette question là en
particulier vous estimer qu'elle est
plus importante que toutes les autres
formes d'engagement de mobilisation oui
il faut hiérarchiser un peu les
problèmes les problèmes de fin de mois
oui c'est un vrai sujet mais l'écologie
c'est il n'y a plus de planètes
si on n'a pas d'avenir on pourra pas
vivre et donc ces problèmes-là
n'existeront plus pascal blain vous des
manifs vous avez dû en faire un certain
nombre comme militant écologiste
est ce que ça vous a surpris interpellé
remis en cause comment vous avez regardé
ces manifestations du 15 mars celle du
lendemain où il y avait toutes les
générations mais celle du 15 mars
peut-être particulièrement alors je suis
je suis père et j'ai effectivement des
enfants qui étaient dans la rue aussi le
15 mars et cela ne peut être une grande
joie de voir ces jeunes aujourd'hui se
mobiliser et dire c'est nous que ça
concerne effectivement avec mes cheveux
blancs j'ai quelques quelques heures de
vol j'ai envie de dire quand j'ai
commencé on pouvait dire que les gens ne
savaient pas on n'avait pas cette
conscience là et depuis je crois que
beaucoup de choses ont été amenés
beaucoup d'éléments les scientifiques se
sont positionnés on parle du giec mais
il faut avoir en tête tous est ce
climato sceptisme entretenu au fil des
années qui existe encore un qui existent
quand on écoute les discours de là le
drame par exemple il suffit de regarder
pas très loin de chez nous c'est encore
une réalité
mais tout ça ne fait que retarder
quelque chose de fatal et sur lequel il
nous faut réagir
la réaction des jeunes pour moi est très
saine et j'applaudis des deux
évidemment alors patrick châteaux
j'imagine que vous applaudissez aussi en
tant qu élue europe écologie les verts
mais est ce que est ce que finalement ça
ne vous interpelle pas en vous disant ah
on aurait peut-être pu anticiper ces
mouvements là ils réagir avant alors
effectivement je suis interpellé je me
suis posé un certain nombre de questions
je me rappelle aussi eu mon histoire
leblanc vous n'aviez leur âge vous étiez
déjà en train de manifester pour les
questions climatiques alors à 15 ans en
74 et le big bang de l'écologie
politique
c'était rené dumont s'est présenté à
l'élection présidentielle est candidat
écolo là il est venu avec un verre d'eau
il a alerté sur le fait que dans 50 ans
on aurait des problèmes pour simplement
trouver de l'eau potable
voilà il était visionnaire mais depuis
voilà en 79
j'avais votre âge j'ai voté pour la
première fois en 78 les rapports du giec
les premiers c'était en 1988 il ya
trente ans donc à votre âge je n'étais
pas fort mais on n'était pas en capacité
avait pas internet
non c'est vrai que il ya différence
générationnelle
après je suis très heureux que vous
soyez là que vous soyez investi j'ai vu
les jeunes manifester j'ai vu qu'il
manifestait dans la dynamique marchait
sur un bon rythme plus un rythme plus
dynamique que les manifestations
traditionnelles avec les syndicats etc
et moi j'ai en fait je vous attendais je
vous attendais pour parce que vous vous
êtes rallier à nos idées peut-être pas
elles se sont même pas rendu compte ce
que vous portez accepter les veaux c'est
ce que nous on porte et pour le monde
n'avait pas beaucoup été écoutés on a
été beaucoup moqué on ait été ignoré ont
maintenant on est copié sur cette
relation ou pas qu'il peut y avoir entre
vous mais sur le principe même ces
manifestations elles ont été là pour
alerter notamment les gouvernants les
élus ceux qui dirigent la planète à
l'échelle supérieure
moi j'avais l'impression que l'écologie
certains me contrediront peut-être
c'était on nous disait depuis très
longtemps mais vous faites attention
chacun doit y mettre du sien on trie les
déchets ont fait pas de gaspillage enfin
voilà les petites choses du quotidien
qui vont faire bouger les choses vous
vous dites non mais
ça on le sait déjà où je sais pas mais
ce sont aux dirigeants de prendre des
décisions maintenant mais il sait ça
tout à fait parce que maintenant qu'on a
agi notre échelle c'est bien mais le
changement doit être plus global plus
grand à une échelle nationale
internationale l'échelle planétaire et
le mouvement des jeunes notamment je
pense permet d'insuffler justement un
regard des consciences par le bas pour
que les politiciens se voit qu'il faut
réagir maintenant ça veut dire quoi les
sifflets à queue basse qu'on devait
faire dans le quotidien vous par exemple
vous le faites vous êtes déjà écolo dans
votre quotidien donc ça nous on voit
bien que ça ne suffit pas pour impulser
des grands changements oui tout à fait
il faut arrêter aussi de donner des
leçons à tout va aux classes populaires
n'y a pas que nous tle d'ailleurs avec
un récent sondage bva on voit que les
les habitudes de tri sélectif de soins
dans l'alimentation sont rentrés comme d
habitude familiale et donc nous vous
avez c'est déjà votre quotidien ça c'est
notre quotidien et surtout on n'a pas
les moyens aussi par exemple d'acheter
une voiture électrique ou de passer à
d'autres moyens
donc ça à l'état de nous donner les
moyens et de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour contrer le
réchauffement climatique les efforts des
citoyens c'est une chose
ce que demandent ces jeunes du monde
entier c'est assez incroyable c'est
l'exemplarité des politiques publiques
ça doit vous parlez patrick châteaux
tout à fait et alexis ça a raison les
personnes les plus démunies les
catégories les plus modestes ce sont
elles aussi qui sont les comportements
les plus vertueux et ça on le mesure au
niveau de notre pays
mais on le mesure aussi au niveau de la
planète et au niveau de la planète ce
sont les pays les plus les plus fragiles
qui sont qui subissent le plus d'impact
donc sur ce point là complètement
complètement d'accord est ce que ça veut
dire que vous pensez que sont les états
qui bloque les dirigeants qui bloque
pour avancer vraiment dans ce combat
contre le changement climatique
berry longet c'est quelque chose qui est
compliqué à mettre en place de toute
façon et ça ça oblige les politiciens à
faire des concessions sur d'autres
sujets et ça peut aussi mettre en jeu
leur popularité parce que c'est des
décisions qui doivent être forte
m
presque radicale vu l'urgence mais du
coup il y à un blocage tout blocage vous
le constater depuis longtemps ce blocage
pascal la la démission de nicolas hulot
évoqué tout à l'heure en est
symptomatique le poids des lobbys est
extrêmement fort en france et les
politiques malgré un discours de plus en
plus vers ou verdi ce verdict qui ce
verdit en tout cas continue à prendre
des décisions du siècle passé sur un
grand nombre de politiques
on le voit dans cette difficulté par
exemple de la sortie du glyphosate qui
pourrait être l'arbre qui cache la forêt
parce qu'il ya pas que le glyphosate
évidemment on voit que tout le monde est
d'accord pour en sortir mais il y en a
c'est en 2050 d'autres c'est la
problématique énergétique avec la sortie
du nucléaire encore une fois il s'agit
de gagner du temps pour ceux qui sont
les porteurs de ces actifs on a
l'impression que finalement tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire il faut
sauver la planète ça souffre pas de
discussion
encore que on doit pouvoir de vous
trouver des gens qui sont contre mais la
question c'est plutôt vous vous dites
c'est urgent c'est tout de suite c'est
maintenant c'est pas dans vingt ans
parce que c'est notre avenir à nous qui
est en jeu vous avez 16 ans c'est ça oui
c'est le problème est que l'action doit
être prises le plus rapidement possible
le changement aurait pu s'opérer il ya
déjà trente ans petit à petit mais ça
aurait justement éviter que dans dix ans
il soit radical or nous dirigeons ce
vraiment sur un changement radical dont
peut-on alors il ya une personne qui est
à l'origine de 2,7 grève mondial des
jeunes du 15 mars dernier elle s'appelle
greta tanberg c'est une écologiste
suédoise elle a été très remarquée lors
de la cop 24 notamment par son discours
c'est si votre modèle c'est votre source
d'inspiration que ce que vous diriez
alexis c'est elle qui a lancé le
mouvement
donc c'est on la suit on suit ce qu'elle
fait mais bien sûr c'est à l'initiative
de chacun d'aller marcher et elle a
donné une impulsion je pense plus qu'un
modèle sur votre point de vue c'est oui
voilà tout à fait c'est elle a peur elle
a montré que c'était possible que nous
aussi on pouvait agir qu'on était
légitime de le faire mais de là une
source d'inspiration je pense pas non
plus une source d'inspiration quand elle
dit
son fameux discours à la coop 24 vous
dites que vous aimez vos enfants plus
que tout mais vous détruisez leur futur
devant leurs yeux est donc à 16 à 16 ans
on peut avoir une conscience écolo et
une conscience politique et greta denber
qu'elle a compris quelque chose
d'essentiel
c'est que c'est pas la planète qui est
en danger c'est l'humanité qui est
engagée sur la planète
la vie est apparue cette vie et les
végétale à 97%
elle est animal à 3% et puis dans le
monde animal
il ya l'humanité cette humanité qui
manque un parcours exceptionnel est
exceptionnelle mais aussi qui par son
mode de vie
un impact maintenant sur l'ensemble des
écosystèmes
donc je crois que greta turnberry a tout
compris vous les jeunes vous avez tout
compris effectivement les décideurs
doivent maintenant je dirais changer de
braquet prendre des décisions rapides
plus plus plus forte plus plus
impactante nous les écologistes nous
sommes souvent dans des coalitions ou
avant qu'une décision soit prise nous
devons d'abord convaincre des sceaux
avec qui nous sommes en condition et
sans coalition vous n'arrivez pas au
pouvoir et en revanche quand on est
quand on est au pouvoir il ya quelques
exemples je pourrais citer jean françois
caron le maire de loos-en-gohelle dans
les hauts de france vous pourrez
assister hier de grenoble damien carême
le maire de grande synthe eric piolle à
grenoble et puis dans notre région
iron man jean macé
à dents puiser à saints en puisaye voie
lactée un maire très engagé il a réussi
à sauver à protéger ses zones de captage
en installant des en faisant la
promotion de l'agriculture biologique
laquelle après fournit la cantine de son
village
est ce que ça vous parle ça l'engagement
politique par exemple à travers un parti
comme europe ecologie les verts qui a
fait un petit peu son fonds de commerce
à le l'engagement pour pour la planète
et pour l'environnement est-ce que c'est
selon vous vu de votre génération comme
ça qu'il faut changer les choses ou
est-ce que c'est plus transversale berry
longet de toute façon le changement doit
être d'un point de vue écologique
économique et sociale à la fois pour
être durable donc savons-nous / les
choses c'est global votre autre
mouvement n'est pas finalement que sur
sur la question de l'environnement il ya
d'autres questions derrière cela si on
veut réussir avec un passing préhension
transition écologique viable et durable
de toute façon faut prendre en compte
les autres facteurs qui vont avec alexis
oui bah on voit qu europe ecologie les
verts est un parti qui attire plus de
jeunes parce qu'ils ne se retrouvent pas
dans les partis mais en même temps c'est
aujourd'hui entre 7 et 9% les sondages
pour les européennes c'est à dire que en
gros ils sont pas en tête donc a priori
pourront pas beaucoup faire changer les
choses
à l'heure où on parle on pourrait
prendre par exemple les dernières
élections présidentielles
on voit bien que le score est assez
limité pour europe1 fr c'est quand même
comme ça qu'ils ont fermé les jeunes et
ben c'est compliqué parce que il ya
beaucoup de facteurs qui rentrent en
compte et la jeunesse aujourd'hui est
assez réticente face au parti face à la
politique en général et donc on voit
bien nicolas hulot l'a montré est ce
qu'il n'ya pas dans la politique
une limite écologique ça fait trois fois
qu'on parle dans cette émission de
nicolas hulot parce que pour vous on
parlait de greta tanberg il ya un
instant pour vous nicolas hulot ça reste
un symbole et aussi peut-être un symbole
de l'échec de l'écologie en politique
tout à fait c'est c'est presqu'un un
écoeurement quoi qui a parce que on voit
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui peut faire
quelque chose au pouvoir qui pourrait
avoir le pouvoir de faire quelque chose
et il se trouve bloquée alors allez-y
ville pascal blain pour réagir sur
kristen bell tout à l'heure pour moi
c'est vrai faire le lien avec nicolas
hulot lors notre génération c'est ça il
faut sortir aussi des totems il faut
sortir ces personnages qui sont les
sauveurs qui sont les les personnages
charismatiques parce qu'encore une fois
ce que derrière great and john bercow il
faut il faut bien sentir c'est que c'est
l'ensemble de la jeunesse mondiale qui
est prêt à se mobiliser et mais elle a
besoin aussi parfois deux porte-paroles
d'emblèmes et nicolas hulot à une époque
en a été un tout à fait ses
porte-paroles ces médiateurs c'est aussi
le rôle de la société civile organisée
c'est le rôle du monde associatif c'est
le rôle du politique et il a été
tellement discrédité ces dernières
années qu'on va vers des tensions on l'a
vu dans la rue ces derniers jours ces
derniers mois s'il n'y a pas cette
organisation minimaliste qui permet
d'organiser la parole effectivement
l'affrontement se trouve de plus en plus
présent et si je me réjouis moi de voir
un mouvement non violent avec ses
mouvements de jeunesse
on ne sait pas où ça peut aller si on
reste dans l'immobilisme donc je
voudrais vraiment que les politiques
entendent que c'est pas tel ou tel qui
est tient à la meilleure oui mais c'est
bien la masse les citoyens qui sont
aujourd'hui prêts à jouer avec ces gars
et deux mondes ces changements il ya un
mois un effet groupe qui est important
parti château louis joly à nicolas hulot
il a été journaliste il a été engagé
dans le secteur associatif et il a été
au pouvoir
quinze mois dans un gouvernement et au
bout d'un certain temps il s'est aperçu
que les engagements qu'on lui avait
données n'ont pas été tenues et il s'est
aperçu du poids des lobbys et là il est
parti il l'a fait de manière
enfin disons fracassant quand on valoir
à son constat est terrible
son concept d'acquérir un constat
d'échec est pour moi cet événement de la
démission nicolas hulot c'est un
changement d'époque dans l'écologie
politique
il ya eu la première époque comme je
vous le disais 1974 2018 45 ans voilà
pendant ce temps là il ya eu la prise de
conscience nous les écologistes on a été
des lanceurs d'alert et là maintenant on
change d'époque
moi je dirais on change d'air et depuis
l'été dernier la démission de nicolas
hulot greta tome berg qui alertent
d'abord son pays ensuite l'europe
finalement le monde entier et là on est
dans une nouvelle époque et il va
falloir alors je me destine aux et la
prochaine question de ce côté de la
table ce que je connais à peu près la
réponse mais puisqu'on parle de nicolas
hulot et son départ du gouvernement
si je vous montre la photo des manuels
macro où on va la voir après celles de
nicolas hulot
vous diriez écolo pas écolo emmanuel
macron notre président de la république
qui se mouillent alexis dans les
décisions sont faibles pour face à
l'enjeu écologique est et il continue ce
qu'on parlait avant de donner des leçons
aux classes populaires sur le fait de
trier
il n'y a pas que nous qui devons croyez
qu'ils trient pas les déchets si peu
qu'on s'y peut-être mais c'est aussi à
l'état c'est surtout à l'état a
aujourd'hui entre les mesures à prendre
des mesures et on va vous dire quelle
mesure ça coûte cher
oui bah oui mais c'est toujours le
problème somme que quand on sait que
1000 milliards sont sortis en quelques
jours
pour sauver les banques en 2008
aujourd'hui c'est la fête de l'humanité
qui en jeu dont complice et 1000
milliards on peut les sortir pour nous
pour notre avenir pour l'humanité et
mairie louise harel sûr il ya des belles
paroles n'y a pas d'actes c'est ce qui
manque
et peut-être que sur le court terme oui
ça va coûter cher mais sur le long terme
forcément ce sera moins cher alors voir
venir à votre engagement comment il peut
poursuivre de quelle façon dans un
instant mais on a vu une absence
vraiment important ça crevait les yeux
dans les manifestations des gilet jaune
ou dans le grand débat national les
jeunes de votre génération je rappelle
que vous avez 16 ans tous les deux
étaient cruellement absents est ce que
vous comprenez ce mouvement d gilet
jaune est ce que il vous semble
antinomique avec le vôtre est ce qu'il
pourrait y avoir des rapprochements
comment comment vous regardez ça ça va
être père comme je disais tout à l'heure
il ya pourra réussir la transition
écologique faut que ce soit aussi d'un
point de vue social et donc il ya des
biens il ya des éléments qui forcément
sont communs ou de nouveau alexine tout
à fait je suis tout à fait d'accord s'il
ya pas mais vous ne vous êtes pas vous
vous étiez dans la rue le 15 mars mais
où le samedi vous n'y allez pas non il
ya c'est faut faire la part des choses
et je je comprends les revendications
des filets jaunes je les soutiens mais
les aller dans la rue pour manifester
jeu pour moi à 16 ans je ne me verrais
pas agiter bien le 15 mars mais j'étais
le 15 mars alors à peut-être une petite
difficulté à vous rapprocher de ce
mouvement la wii peut être est ce que
est ce que aussi c'est pas parce que le
point de départ il n'est pas très écolo
moi je vous le dis très clairement le
point de départ c'est la taxe sur le
carburant
j'ai besoin d'aller travailler avec ma
voiture parce que je travaille à
distance de mon domicile j'ai pas
forcément des fans - très facile ça me
coûte de devoir payer plus cher mon
carburant et le carburant ça pollue
est-ce que c'est pas aussi ça qui est un
qui est finalement très différente votre
mouvement
oui une part de choses mais en même
temps le
les les au point de vue social si on
donne pas si le gouvernement donne pas
des moyens aux gens les gens ne pourront
pas aussi être écolo dans leur vie en
fait pourquoi supprimer les primes etc
et les déductions fiscales dont je suis
grand et scandaient dieu sait que c'est
toujours les plus pauvres sur lequel on
va faire porter la pression sous couvert
d'écologie
il faut être réaliste aujourd'hui les
plus gros pollueurs sont ceux qui payent
le moins
par exemple les navires qui amène
l'essentiel de nos marchandises en
europe et en france
brûle un pétrole brut qui n'est pas
taxée
le kérosène brûlé dans les avions n'est
pas taxée quand vous dites ces deux
mouvements ils sont pas contradictoires
ils sont pas antinomiques tout à fait il
n'y aura pas de justice climatique s'il
n'y a pas de justice sociale les deux
choses doivent marcher de pair et oui il
faudra demain que la taxe carbone
permettent d'être vrai levier pour aller
vers qu'elle mène ça va de la cassure
mais il faut accompagner les plus
précaires et les plus fragiles
évidemment alors je vais me retourner
encore vers les jeunes de cette émission
parce que on se pose la question
descendre dans la rue une fois le 15
mars
vous l'avez fait beaucoup en face de
vous sont admiratifs de cette
mobilisation et de son ampleur est ce
que c'est le début d'un engagement est
ce que c'est un one shot
et puis vous passerez au reste après
comment vous voyez les choses
tout d'abord on on s'est dit qu'on
n'allait pas marcher toutes les semaines
ce qu'on voulait pas endormir les
consciences non plus et non ça c'est ça
c'est un petit tacle pour les gilet
jaune non qui eux manifestent toutes les
semaines est-ce qu'ils en donnent la
conscience est-ce qu'ils ont semblé
conscience moi je voulais c'est ce que
je disais c'était que donc du coup on
voulait attendre en fait on attendait de
voir ce concept d'édition peuvent pas
être prises en une semaine deux semaines
et donc on voulait voir si au bout d'un
moment il y à du tennis aux décisions
prises ou pas et s'il n'y a pas de
surprise dans ce cas on devra marcher
autrement sinon notamment on essaiera de
faire des cliniques etc
oui tout à fait et peut-être des actions
de sensibilisation notamment
rendez vous qui va être urbana liste à
dijon le 13 avril qui va être tour d'une
séance de travail sur qu'est-ce que le
changement climatique parce que vous
avez des propositions concrètes que vous
avez d'ailleurs présenté aux élus alors
vous vous êtes de l'agglomération
dijonnaise aux élus de l'agglomération
dijonnaise
vous avez des solutions très concrètes
pour nous ici au delà des grands débats
sur le climat au niveau mondial oui tout
d'abord ben que la ville on a demandé à
monsieur rebsamen de déclarer l'état
d'urgence climatique pour qui va
permettre de créer un groupe de citoyens
engagés donc de jeunes comme de moins
jeunes et pour filtrer les décisions et
donner des mesures au conseiller aux
conseillers municipaux mais aussi on
voulait on veut demande une continuité
dans le réseau de pistes cyclables on
demande de massifier les composts et les
poubelles à déchets donc de trouver un
sacré coup de main pathé château dans
votre majorité plurielle on va dire pour
reprendre un terme anciens parce que eux
ils soutiennent finalement ce que vous
essayez vous pousser dans votre majorité
et qui n'a pas toujours échos d'ailleurs
exactement mais voulait très bien
formulée moi j'ai lu avec avec vraiment
grande attention les douze les douze
revendications entre guillemets que vous
avez formulé effectivement moi je nous
les écologistes on se rejoint avec vous
avec ce que vous nous avez dit sûr c'est
sur ces revendications c'est que leur
engagement peut aller plus loin que la
simple manifestation que la prochaine
qu'ils organisent s'ils n'ont pas gain
de cause
les clichés sur la génération y z hyper
connectés individualiste enfermés dans
les applications et les réseaux sociaux
on a l'impression qu'ils sont en train
de les démonter écoutez libre à eux moi
je n'ai pas de deux recommandations à
leur faire ils nous prouvent de toute
manière qu'ils sont complètement
responsable qui maîtrise les enjeux
moi je dirais que il ya quarante ans
j'étais jeune comme eux ensuite j'ai
milité dans le mouvement associatif et
puis pour ne rien vous cacher c'est la
suite de la création d'une amap qui a un
peu plus de dix ans je suis entre
guillemets rentrer en politique et je
suis devenu élu s persie
sont là je vous pose la question à tous
les deux c'est pas parce que vous avez
raté quelque chose dans cet engagement à
société nova est ce qu'on peut se
remettre en cause
pascal blain est ce que vous vous avez
l'impression que dans tout cet
engagement à un moment donné s'ils sont
encore à faire les mêmes demandes que
dans le début des années 70 c'est
peut-être que vous voulez militants
écologistes vous avez raté quelque chose
de tout à fait des d'un stade
d'informations à un stade d' alerte à un
stade d'interpellations il ya un moment
il faut passer à l'acte et donc pas le
politique et le prolongement un de ces
démarches
mais j'ai envie de dire nous on a vécu
de l'intérieur dans le monde associatif
on a vécu de l'intérieur la mutation de
de la tente par rapport à l'engagement
très concrètement mois ces jeunes ne
feint pas ces deux là en particulier
tout ce qui m'arrive on les voit chaque
fois qu'on organise par exemple des
chantiers iqu volontaires pour aller
nettoyer un bourg de rivière pour aller
planter une haie est l'histoire aller
plus loin et dans l'engagement c'est ça
ma question alors leur manière à changer
effectivement ils vont plus aujourd'hui
dire je prends une carte jeune
association dans un parti politique
exactement mais par contre ils vont être
capables spontanément sont organisées
dans leurs quartiers dans avec leur
groupe de camarades des actions
concrètes ou lycées dans le quartier il
nous reste deux minutes
est ce que cet engagement il peut se
transformer ou est ce que ce sont des
vieilles façons de s'engager le le
militantisme associatif ou politique
mérite non je pense qu'il ya rien qui a
banni re ou à rejeter tout est bon à
prendre et c'est aussi en ayant sur
plusieurs fronts qu'on va réussir à
changer mais vous n'allez pas
spontanément prendre une carte à france
nature environnement dans une des
associations de france nature
environnement
alex possible oui mais c'est pas
forcément là aujourd'hui les jeunes ont
du mal à aller directement dans des
associations derrière le mouvement eut
fort climat dit jean les jeunes se
sentent dans leur sphère ils sont avec
des amis sur les réseaux sociaux ils
seraient pas allés directement sur dont
bas dans une association comme anne v
comme 21 ou d'autres associations
d'instruction après château dans
l'intéressante dans l'urgence climatique
il ya urgence
donc pas très rapidement il faut aller
plus vite c'est ça c'est le message des
jeunes
c'est le message des jeunes nous par
exemple on a initié beaucoup de choses à
dijon le bio dans les cantines est passé
de 10 à 30% en 4e mais le message s'est
s'est passé mais maintenant c'est passé
et maintenant il faut il faut aller à
100%
les composteurs collectifs bon il y en a
une soixantaine sur la sur la métropole
mais il faut encore il faut aller plus
loin toute revendication
moi je pense que sont pertinentes mais
l'essentiel c'est le rythme il faut
aller plus vite
le message est passé obligation de
résultat le message est passé merci à
tous d'avoir accepté de répondre à ces
questions et de débattre aujourd'hui en
direct merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
dans un instant à point sur l'actualité
régionale avec elle a besoin
suivi de la partie nationale de dimanche
en politique francis letellier reçoit
franck riester le ministre de la culture
bon dimanche à tous sur france 3
[Musique]